انت يعني يعني رفقت هذه التجربه
تجربه التامل والتفكير هذه المنطقه خاصه
بالانظمه
الانظمه العربيه اللي احتل العسكر رفات
وتاملت فيها وكتبت فيها الكثير الى ان
توصلت مرورا بالثورات طبعا وحتى الان يعني
في هذا التاريخ نحن هلا 2023
باواخر فبراير
يبدو انت
وتكرر اظن هذا الكلام انه
لم تجد املا يعني محبط
لديك احساس بالخيبه
ولكن دائما الامل مقفل بظنك
ما بعرف يعني القصه اذا كان فعلا يعني مثل
بعض بصيغوها تفاؤل وتشاؤم وامل وياس بس
اذا وضعنا جانبا
الاوصاف يعني
الواقع القائم العمى نعيشه واقع مسدود
واقع مسدود فعلي يعني مثلا تخيل
نظام النظام بشار الاسد بعده حي يرزق شيء
مثل العراق
بلد غني بكل معاني الكلمه
ما عم يقدر يقلع ما عم يقدروا يقف على
رجلي يعني مطروح وجوده على المحك بلد مثل
لبنان كان ذات مره
هيك التجربه العربيه المطله على العالم
المحل اللي في درجه بعيده جدا من الحريات
السياسيه والنقابيه والاعلاميه والى اخره
وصل للحاله الزهريه اللي نعرفها هلا
يعني كتير بشع انك تلاقي
بمعزل
المتشائمين او متفائلين
انك تلاقي وضع يعني هذا بتضربه مثل
البلدان اللي
ماضيها احسن من حاضرها وحاضرها حيكون احسن
مستقبلها لانه كمان في احيان كثيره
ومجتمعاته بلدان بتتردى وبتتراجع بس مبين
في بصيص نور في امل في شيء ممكن تبني عليه
لمرحله لاحقه هون ما مبين ابدا